des salariés de la mgen inquiets pour
leur emploi ont manifesté ce matin à
paris dans les rangs de l'intersyndicale
des employés de l'antenne de la verrière
principale cause de leur mécontentement
la révision annoncée de la convention
collective de la fédération des
établissements hospitaliers et des aides
à la personne
l'aménagement d'usagé propre à la mgen
et l'externalisation de certains
services
leinen s'est pas donné les moyens de
faire une étude de l'intérieur au privé
en quoi l'externalisation et est
forcément meilleure mais en quoi on
aurait pu faire différemment à
l'intérieur en termes de ressources
deuxièmement l'ensemble des personnels à
bénéficier régulièrement des formations
et 6 ans d'aujourd'hui couillard
dysfonctionnement c'est la
responsabilité de la mgen de déverser
tous les moyens pour former et adapter
le personnel aux évolutions qui sont
demandés du côté de la direction locale
de la mgen jean ignace de bayou affirme
connais rien organisation est nécessaire
pour revenir à un équilibre financier
l'établissement derrière roy perd plus
d'argent qu'il n'en gagne
parmi les usages remis en cause on
retrouve notamment les rythmes de
travail
l'institut marcel rivière par exemple
nous avons l'habitude de travailler avec
des avec une absence de cycle horaires
une salariée non pas de cycle régulier
ça a un coût en équivalent temps plein
sur une année et donc c'était un usage
qui est dénoncée qu'on doit on doit
faire des cycles la mgen compte 33
établissements répartis dans toute la
france ce qui représente un total de
4000 salariés pour les 200 employés de
la verrière une seule certitude pour
l'instant une externalisation partir du
1er décembre de la restauration et de
l'entretien
le directeur assure que les employés de
ces services seront repris dans les
entreprises sous traitantes
un message entendu mais pas satisfaisant
pour l'intersyndicale qui craint des
suppressions de postes